[Music]
thank you thank you
I want to go back to the beginning and
talk about why we do nuclear physics why
is nuclear physics interesting first the
nucleus consists is a unique form of
matter consisting of many baryons in
close proximity all the forces of nature
are present in the nucleus strong
electromagnetic weak it provides a
unique microscopic laboratory for
testing the nature of the fundamental
interactions the nucleus manifests
remarkable properties as a strongly
interacting quantum mechanical mini body
system you saw some of these illustrated
in the lovely pictures of Steve Koonin
yesterday after all most of the mass and
energy in the visible universe comes
from nuclei and nuclear reactions we now
know that the nucleus is composed of a
new underlying set of degrees of freedom
quarks and gluons held together with
remarkable new forces described by QCD
quantum chromodynamics the baryon itself
is a complicated many-body system
nuclear physics is crucial to the
understanding of the universe the early
universe the formation of the elements
supernovae neutron stars to me nuclear
physics is really the study of the
structure of matter in 1989 the field of
nuclear physics formulated a long-range
plan for the next decade and I've just
listed the chapter titles in the the
section titles in the chapter to
scientific frontiers to give you a taste
of where nuclear physics is and where
it's going nucleons and nuclei hadrons
in nuclei quarks and nuclei and hadrons
flavor physics essentially strangeness
in nuclei the nucleus under extreme
conditions the dynamics and
thermodynamics of colliding nuclei
confined and D confined phases of
nuclear matter precision precision tests
of the fundamental interactions and
nuclear physics in the universe
we actually have three levels of
understanding of nuclear physics the
first is what I like to call the
traditional nonrelativistic many-body
problem you use two body potentials the
many-body Schrodinger equation and then
construct currents from the properties
of free nucleons at another level we can
describe the nucleus as an interacting
relativistic mini body system employing
hadronic degrees of freedom baryons and
mesons and quantum field theory I like
to call this qHD or quantum
hydrodynamics at the deepest level we
know the nucleus is a strongly coupled
system of colored quarks and gluons
interacting our description is based on
a yang-mills theory based on internal
color symmetry that theory has two
absolutely remarkable properties
asymptotic freedom at short distances
the particles are effectively weakly
interacting and confining we do not see
the underlying degrees of freedom as
asymptotic scattering states in the
laboratory why electron scattering well
first the interaction is known it's
given by quantum electrodynamics the
interaction is relatively weak and this
means we can make measurements on the
target without greatly disturbing its
structure we interact with the local
electromagnetic current density in the
target what we measure is essentially
the Fourier transform of the transition
matrix element of the local
electromagnetic current density in the
target multiplied by the molar potential
or the appropriate lepton matrix element
an electron scattering has the great
advantage that we can vary the three
momentum transfer and energy transfer
independently thus for a fixed energy
transfer to the target we can vary the
three momentum transfer and map out the
Fourier transform of the transition
densities and just to give you the
classic example
this is the diffraction pattern you see
if you scatter electrons elastically
from from the calcium 4t nucleus this is
cross-section or intensity versus
momentum transfer or effectively
scattering angle at fixed incident
energy and here is an actual diffraction
pattern maxima and minima you see these
rings of maximum in a minima in the
laboratory I asked you to notice the
scale here the scale goes over 13
decades by inverting that Fourier
transform we can actually determine the
charge density in the calcium 4t nucleus
this is charge density it's a function
of distance from the center in Fermi's
the little green band indicates the
experimental uncertainty in inverting
that Fourier transform the heavy dashed
line indicates the description of the
charge density in qHD dotted and dashed
lines are a description in the
traditional picture as shown by Steve
Koonin yesterday by varying the electron
kinematics we can actually separate the
interaction with the charge and current
density in the target that interaction
is actually very rich because not only
is there a Coulomb interaction with the
charges in the target there is a
magnetic interaction with the convection
current in the target arising from the
motion of the charges and also with the
curl of the intrinsic magnetization in
the target there's an intrinsic
magnetization because after all nucleons
are little magnets another advantage of
electron scattering is by going to large
momentum transfer we can bring out high
multiples
electrons let's provide a precision tool
for looking at the nucleus and one of
course the great advantage of electrons
is that can be copiously produced in the
laboratory in addition their
interference effects arising from the
exchange of in addition to a photon of a
z0 and those can be seen by looking at
parity violation for example looking at
the difference in cross-section for
right and left-handed electrons the S
matrix is essentially what we wrote
before with an additional term which for
heavy Z's is again just the weak lepton
matrix element now times the Fourier
transform of the matrix element of the
weak neutral current density in the
target we know this has both a vector
and axial vector component and that's by
looking at the product of these two
terms and the product of those two terms
and interfering them with this we have
parity violation if this is now assumed
known and measured we can in fact
measure this and that it means we can
use electrons to measure the
distribution of weak neutral current in
the nuclear system these experiments are
terribly difficult but in fact in a tour
de force experiment completed debates
doing elastic scattering from carbon-12
the feasibility of such measurements has
now been established and we're ready for
the next generation of those
measurements in addition BR cane scaling
and deep inelastic in the deep inelastic
region provides dynamical evidence for
quarks allows a measurement of the quark
momentum distribution and allows us to
test QCD predictions on approach to
scaling cross-section for inclusive
electron scattering essentially measures
two response surfaces which can be
separated by varying the electron
kinematics these response surfaces their
functions of them for momentum transfer
squared and new the Lorentz invariant
which reduces to the energy transfer in
the laboratory system let me give you a
sketch of what these response surfaces
look like just for your orientation in
this and the following talks here I've
sketched the research response services
both for a nucleus and for nucleon this
is the for momentum transfer and this is
essentially the energy transfer except
I've divided by the for momentum
transfer squared and call that variable
one over X so here we see elastic
scattering from the nucleus falling off
with the characteristic form factor we
see excitations of discrete States in
the target giant resonances quasi
elastic scattering scattering from a
single nucleon Doppler broadening motion
scatter we see excitation of various
excited states of the nucleon and in the
case of the nucleon itself if you look
off here at very large K squared
but fixed values of 1 over X in fact the
cross-section the response surfaces are
independent of K square that's be arcane
scaling and that because of the absence
of the form factor that gives us
evidence for the point like dynamic in
point like scattering from the quarks in
the interior if we scatter from discrete
nuclear states then in fact we can make
a multiple analysis of these two
response surfaces the transverse surface
is the sum of the squares of the reduced
matrix elements of the transverse
electric and transverse magnetic
multiples and the Kaja to no response
the Coulomb response is the reduced
matrix element of the Coulomb multiples
now in fact in a talk like this it
doesn't make any sense to
try and give formula but I wanted to
show this transparency for a particular
reason I thought I would tell you how I
got into electron scattering as a
graduate student here working with Vicky
and of course we were brought up on blat
and vice cough which I devoured it's a
monk it's a marvelous book and I
mastered the material in chapters 12 and
Appendix B and for those of you who
don't have total recall those are the
sections on electromagnetic interactions
and multiple analysis and I went to a my
I went to Stanford and as a young
faculty member there I taught nuclear
physics and I went through all those
multiple analyses and I also did the
vice cough estimates yeah which Vicki
mentioned yesterday and the Vice coffee
estimates are simple estimates for the
transit for the relative strength of the
various electromagnetic multiples in
gamma transitions and also at that time
at Stanford there was a young faculty
member who every time he saw me would
corner me and show me this lovely data
on the form factor for the excitation of
the first quadrupole resonance in in
nuclei which had the same form factor
across a wide variety of valence
structures that was Henry Kendall and so
into Jerry Friedman was also there at
that time I think Jerry owned the
deuteron
during that period so to try to get some
insight into this I put together the
multiple analysis which I learned from
Blanton vice cough and it's all there
it's all in black vice coffee together
with a simple dynamical model of
collective excitations and I was hooked
and I haven't looked back since these
are the multiples now the vice cough
estimates are based on the long
wavelength limited the multiples in law
at long wavelength it's only the minimum
multiple arity that contributes to the
transition and the thing that always
excited me about electron scatter
was that in fact by varying the momentum
transfer you can actually see all of
these multiples and in fact under right
conditions you can actually see the
maximum multiple that can contribute to
a scattering and let me just give you a
couple examples of that this is elastic
magnetic scattering from niobium 93 done
it baits this is the momentum transfer
transverse response at low momentum
transfers you see just the magnetic
dipole scattering from the magnetic
dipole moment but then you see the m3 m5
m7 and out here you in fact see the m9
niobium has nine is nine has plus and
the shell model configuration is a G
nine halves proton well what do you
learn from that in fact what you learn
from it is this now I've actually
sketched this for an f7 halves in
vanadium so that I could get it on a ten
Fermi square if you take the vanadium
nucleus and line it up along the z axis
the the intrinsic magnetization also
points along the z axis and this is the
surface of half maximum magnetization
density just to give you a picture of
where the proton actually is in the
vanadium nucleus so in fact by measuring
all of those multiples you can in fact
determine the detailed microscopic
distribution of the current and
magnetization of that last valence
particle in the nucleus you can actually
see that the vanadium nucleus is a
little current loop is a little magnet
and a little current loop and you can
actually measure the distribution of
that current loop and of course since
the neutrons also have intrinsic
magnetization you can measure Neutron
distributions this way also here's an
inelastic cross section again done it
baits 60 degrees Q of two inverse
Fermi's there is one level that
dominates the
rectum and from its form factor that is
the area under that curve it's
identified as an m6 transition well in
fact an m6 is the maximum maximum
multiple arity you can get when you
promote a particle from the one D five
half shell to the one F seven half shell
the maximum multipolarity you can get is
six - six - magnetic transition and by
going to high enough momentum transfer
you can make that dominate the
cross-section let's move on to a another
part of the spectrum this is the quasi
elastic peak the data is in fact from
Heppell and when I check the reference
it was Mona's at all if they can put me
in an experimental session they can put
you on an experimental paper this the
curve is a calculation by Rosenfeld ER
and it's based on a relativistic mean
field theory and local density
approximation using a density from the
relative relativistic archery
calculation so in fact there no
parameters in that it's a fully
relativistic calculation conserved
current and the description of that data
is all that you could ask so you think
you really understand what's going on in
the quasi elastic region well what
should be even simpler should be the
Coulomb response because after all that
just comes from the charges the Coulomb
response is much significantly less than
this and to separate it you have to do
make a Rosenbluth plot people have
worked very hard to do that over past
several years and when you do it you
find this if you take the area under the
Coulomb response which is which is the
Coulomb sum rule then this is in fact
what you see in calcium for T these are
the experimental points and this is a
curve calculated exactly the same way as
the theoretical curve on the previous
picture so in fact the experimental
Coulomb response falls below
best theoretical estimates place
something like a factor of two now you
can say okay maybe that's correlations
because if you remember the Coulomb sum
rule properly normalized the area under
the Coulomb response is 1 plus the
Fourier transform of the two body proton
proton density in fact this is familiar
in condensed matter physics with neutron
scattering you measure the Fourier
transform of the two body density all
the time well I did some calculations
this is one minus the inelastic sum rule
and this is what you get if you just had
a Fermi gas this is for nuclear matter
this is these are poly correlations just
just with a firm non-interacting Fermi
gas and then I took the Fourier
transform of the two body density that
Vicki and Luis Carlos Gomez and I had
used in our discussions of nuclear
matter if you have just a hard core you
get that if you have a more realistic
Markovski Scott potential you get
something like this well in the region
of highest energy on the previous
picture you might get something like a
10% reduction it's very difficult to see
how you could get anything like a factor
of 2 reduction I would say the fact that
the experimental value of the Coulomb
sum rule which should be the simplest
thing that we have in nuclear physics
the fact the world our theoretical
understanding of that is off almost by a
factor of 2 is really one of the major
outstanding problems in nuclear physics
well people have talked about this
correlation function for years it is
after all the basis of our calculation
of all the properties of nuclear matter
what is the to body density look like at
short distances in the nucleus in fact
it's never been measured that is it's
never been measured until recently it
was measured at Bates it was measured
for a simple system which is helium-3
but one nice thing about helium-3 is
that you have a calibration check
because you can also do the experiment
from tritium which has only one proton
and there is no proton proton
correlation in a one proton system so in
fact here is the this is the Fourier
transform of the two body proton density
in tritium and here's what it is in
helium-3 and for the first time we have
some knowledge of what the two body
distribution is in short distances in
nuclei coming from electrons get let me
go on to another part of the spectrum
this is the excitation of the nucleon
this is part of the original slack MIT
collaboration experiment
it's beautiful data it's even more
impressive if you realize that the
elastic peak has been suppressed the
elastic peak doesn't occur on this curve
so in fact this is the excitation of the
Delta and then these are higher higher
resonance groups now I can look at the
form factor or area under that curve as
a function of momentum transfer that's
what it looks like fact this is from
these points are from marty brighton
bucks thesis here at MIT there is one
more point down here that's hard to see
but there's in fact the point here at ke
squared equals 0 coming from photo
production the theoretical curve is a
calculation with essentially within the
framework of qHD it's actually we did it
but it's actually a synthesis of work
done by a lot of people fool beanie
Nambu and Watauga and jaggery denry
adler it's a hydronic calculation and
the interesting thing which one really
has to contemplate is that the scale
here this is for GeV squared which is a
hundred inverse fermi squared and the
interesting thing is a hydronic
description can work down to that very
short distance scale for this process
well let me say a little bit about why
we do coincident electron scattering so
far I've talked about singles
experiments why do you want to do
coincidence experiments which is in fact
what's going to be made possible by the
pulse stretcher ring here at dates and
by sea bath so now not only do you have
the electron but you can measure what's
coming out of the target in coincidence
and the electron variable set up a nice
coordinate system here the momentum
transfer the normal to the scattering
plane and the third perpendicular vector
and theta and fire the usual usual polar
and has musical angles what do you
measure in a coincidence experiment
well you measure the same thing lepton
molar potential Fourier transform
transition matrix element of the current
but now the final state consists of the
asymptotically of the tis a Heisenberg
state it's an eigenstate of the full
Hamiltonian asymptotically it's the
target in whatever state it's in and the
outgoing particle and the only thing is
you have to use incoming wave boundary
conditions well what do you learn from
this well first first thing you can do
if you realize that if you go to a
discrete state of the target J PI then
in fact you're doing in it you can do an
angular correlation experiment of the
type that Martin Deutsch talked about
yesterday
but in this case you're doing an angular
correlation experiment with the virtual
photon whose energy and momentum you can
vary independently and the outgoing
particle that distribution is
characteristic of this angular momentum
furthermore you no longer have simply
the sums of squares of amplitudes you
have interference terms and that allows
you to determine small amplitudes
through interference again you have a
dial to turn the three momentum transfer
and by turning that dial you can bring
out transitions of different
multipolarity x' in the case of e e
prime p it's particularly simple and
elegant if you knock a proton up and you
measure all the energies then you can
measure the energy of where it came from
or the binding energy of the residual
hole
if you measure all the momenta with the
three momentum transfer and the momentum
of the outgoing particle then
effectively what you measure is the
Fourier transform of that bound state
wave function with respect to the
momentum difference furthermore if we
have a coincidence capability we can
then do double and even triple
scattering experiments on the outgoing
particle to measure polarizations
furthermore if we have enough energy and
kinematic flexibility we can access new
reactions for example EE prime K + + by
Associated production you leave a hyper
on or in quark language you leave a
strange quark in the in the middle of
the nucleus furthermore by doing double
coincidence experiments we can get
another handle on the core nucleon
nucleon correlations in nuclei and
finally we can study the had realization
of quarks the struck quark emerges as a
hadron and we can study how that process
takes place in nuclei I want to give you
just a couple examples of each of these
this is I show this because it's close
to my heart this was the original
coincidence experiment done on the
superconducting accelerator at Apple and
let me tell you what the configuration
is you you arrange the energy transfer
so you excite carbon to the giant dipole
resonance and now you look at the
angular distribution of photons of the
protons going to the ground state of
boron 11 with respect to that momentum
transfer and you see a characteristic
dipole pattern now if you say four
points do not a dipole pattern make you
are right
on the other hand at mites they have now
done that same experiment and this is
the quality of the angular correlation
data you now have from the new
generation of CW electron accelerators
here's an example of the EE prime P
process that I talked about this is from
kneecap this is a e prime P on lead 208
going to valium 207 this is the ground
state a 3 s 1/2 hole
this and here is the characteristic
fall-off of the Fourier transform of a
3sf wave function here's the first
excited whole state a 2d three-halves
here's a characteristic rise and fall of
the Fourier transform of a 2d
three-halves wave function and down here
you see nothing until you increase the
momentum transfer and by gully here all
of a sudden you see an H 11 half coming
up you can you can arrange it so you see
these high spin levels and in fact you
can take the nucleus apart level by
level shell by shell wave function by
wave function this is a experiment that
is ongoing at Bates it's actually
another tour-de-force it's a coincidence
experiment it's actually a triple
coincidence experiment
it's a polarization transfer between a
polarized electron and a polarized
Neutron and by measuring this
polarization transfer you measure an
interference term that's directly
proportional to the electric form factor
of the neutron of course the electric
form factor the neutron it tells you
about the charge distribution in the
neutron okay it's a triple coincidence
experiment because you have to measure
the detected D scattered electron
you've got to know there's a neutron
there and then you have to measure a
scattering asymmetry to determine the
neutron polarization now this is the
actual signal okay and this background
is accidental coincidences and this is
done with a duty factor of a machine
with a duty factor of 1% now I asked you
to think of this as a seamount and this
is an ocean and by increasing the duty
factor you can leave the signal and you
can lower the level of the ocean in fact
it was 100 percent duty factor you can
level lower the ocean by at least tour
as a magnitude and what was a little
peak there now becomes a huge mountain
that's expect the most dramatic evidence
I can show for the advantage of having a
CW machine how am i doing on time bill
five minutes huh four minutes
why see bath let me just say a few words
about see behalf to close there's no
single characteristic that makes see
bath unique rather it's a combination of
characteristics
it's the kinematic range for gev the
intensity to hundred micro amps to 3n
stations it's the duty factor hundred
percent and it's the beam quality the
low immittance and the energy resolution
in the beam and my version of CBF
scientific goal is the study of the
structure of the nuclear many-body
system including the baryon itself it's
quark sub structure and the nature of
the strong and electro weak interactions
governing the behavior of this
fundamental form of matter we have an
approved physics program at C bath and
I've just given you my version of the
general areas of the approved and
conditionally approved proposals
structure a few nucleon systems single
nucleon behavior and nuclei static
properties of the nucleon strangeness
and nuclei correlations in nuclei
dynamic internal properties of the
nucleon mesons and nucleon approach to
deep inelastic scattering and weak
neutral currents in nuclei we have
equipment designed approved and under
construction at sea BAFF we have three
experimental halls we're going to have
complimentary sets of equipment in the
three halls one hall will have a pair of
high resolution four GeV spectrometers
one Hall will have a large acceptance
detector to try and get everything that
comes out in coincidence and the first
hall that will come on the air in less
than two years from now will have a high
momentum spectrometer and a short orbit
spectrometer to look at decaying
particles and I'd like to finish showing
you just a couple examples of the kinds
of data that we expect to get at sea
bass these are from proposals
and this is a set of projected errors it
includes the design of the equipment
efficiency statistics and so on here's
an experiment which will measure the
trend in the polarization of the
outgoing proton in EE prime P reaction
from oxygen-16 and we will have enough
resolution to separate those two peaks
okay and this is what you see if you
reject that proton from a P a half shell
and there's the expected size of the C
bath error bars here are two theoretical
curves that's with a relativistic Dirac
optical potential and that's with a non
relativistic optical potential in the
final state here is the analog of that
Neutron experiment I talked to you about
only done on hydrogen so it's the
polarization X transpose X pyramid on
hydrogen which is which gets you GE P
charge distribution in the proton that's
the world's data and that gives you an
indication of the projected size of the
C bath error bars and kinematic range on
GE P here is the ratio of e 2 to M 1
transition matrix element for the Delta
it's interesting Bob Larese can talk
about that a little bit because you can
get at things like the deformation of
the of the Delta and the nucleon that's
the world's data I asked you to look at
the scale this is now 1/10 and here is
the projected see bath
so this is not 0.05 and there's the set
of projected sea bath error bars for
that particular experiment and this is
kind of interesting this is the a
simulation of the class detector this 4
PI detector this is a simulation of the
Mezen spectra that you'll see PI not ADA
Omega and ADA Prime so in conclusion I
would just like to make two comments
about the relation of MIT to sea bass
the first comment is that the success
and quality of the experimental program
at sea bass the most important single
single most important factor to me in
the quality and success of the
experimental program at sea bass is the
caliber of the young people that have
been produced by this laboratory and in
fact the majority of those people have
been produced by the chairman of this
session the second is that when I went
to see Bath and set up a program
Advisory Committee I wanted to get the
very best people I could I put four
people on from MIT I could could have
put more Ernie Moniz dan kowalski bill
Burtka Lizzy bill Donnelly fact Claude
Williamson was there he was chairman of
the users group at that time I got a lot
of flack for that why do you want to put
on so many people from one institution
but we've got an approved equipment plan
we're building the right equipment and
we've got an approved scientific program
and it's an absolutely first-rate
program so it's a pleasure to come back
to MIT it's interesting when I come back
to MIT and walk through the place I
always feel like I'm coming home and I
think there two reasons for that one is
that I have a lot of very close friends
here
but the second reason is that this is
really where I became a professional
physicist which has really been a deep
source of satisfaction to me through my
whole life and to me mit has been and is
and will continue to be the heart of
that profession
[Applause]